And on mobile, we need to be extra
careful, images consume a lot of
bandwidth, more than 60% of
the bytes that cross the web.
That's bandwidth we can't always rely
on or might not want to use, and
images don't always work so
well on different screen sizes.
This photo from the Tower of London
looks great on my new high DPI display,
but when I resize the window,
the fixed size image gets cropped.
With the same image on my phone,
I need to scroll horizontally and
vertically, and
that's a terrible experience.
The web was actually invented with
responsiveness in mind to enable
us to publish content to
a variety of devices.
We need to think like that again,
and make sure our images work well,
wherever they're seen.
So we can avoid this.
Check out the pixelation
around the eyes on the horse.
And this,
not really seeing the surfer anymore.
And worst of all, this.
I'll leave you with a quote.
Create a product,
don't re-imagine one for small screens.
Great mobile products are created,
never ported.
That's from Brian Fling.
So great designers don't optimize for
mobile,
they think responsively, to build sites
that work across a range of devices.